welcome to this video game 5 of Nizar
championship match between Carlton and
are not in Chennai India and we had four
draws up to now unfortunately you really
want to see a decisive game now and then
that's just yeah just more interesting
to see one player leading the match and
forcing the other one to get to take
bigger risks so let's hope that we get a
decisive game soon okay let's check out
game 5 played today with Carson having
the white pieces and he opens with c4
which is a slight surprise
maybe after he played tonight f 3/2
times but okay I absolutely expecting
him to play a four at some point that
maybe he really decided beforehand that
he focuses on on flank openings in this
match and therefore c4 makes lots of
sense it just prevents the kind of setup
that are not played in the first two
games where he played a quick d5 and g6
again Schneider 3 and of course he
forced the move that really a prevents
tea fire for the time being the only way
d5 is going to be played this after some
prevalence I don't play d6 now and it
seems that Carlton was slightly
surprised by this choice um yeah and
factor I wouldn't have reckoned with
this move as well because anna usually
is not playing the Queens gambit
declined which after Knight c3 d5 would
come up Knight f6 here allows even
so-called Makino's variation that is an
opening that like rarely allows it's
believed to be a bit tricky for black
so surprisingly he cousin plays d4
instead of Knight c3 and now under could
have gone back to yeah his normal ways
playing Knight f6 ecigs to UM decide
later phew we have a new Misawa Queen's
Indian for example but he plays a d5
obviously having a specific idea in mind
that this idea we see quickly this is
six and this is really a surprise
Ananta has used the smooth only very
very occasionally and bring faster time
controls and it's a very sharp choice
for World Championship match simply
because some White has the move before
this is what cousin plays um if he would
have gotten oops this was not intended
if he would have gone for other moves
like Knight f3 yeah Anand has a choice
he can go to now the IDF six to the semi
Slav which is one of his old favorites
since his childhood days also played in
the matches against kramnik against him
against Galvan
I could have played the very sharp
notable this would have been a sensation
if he would have gone for that but okay
he form is some the principal move here
anyway because black neglected the
Foursquare with his pawn moves and this
is really the principled way to go
however after D takes Knight takes check
there's this check and this is one on a
plate here the overwhelming majority of
games has continued with the move Bishop
d2 the so-called Marshall gambit this is
another Marshall gambit and this is a
very dangerous line for for black it
also for Wyatt to be honest because you
give a giving up eccentric
but oops of course not that Bishop
before Jack we need for check this is
how it is played and now White has a
choice between Bishop e2 and 92 not
quite clear what's the best move we
should be to is the most popular moles
and yeah this is a very interesting
position white enjoys the two bishops
especially this Bishop is a very
dangerous piece that prevents castling
and White has very serious compensation
for the pawn in fact them to connect
this match tomb with my own personal
experience I have played this line this
so-called triangle line with c6 very
often it's been a while since I played
it in tournament chess and I always
feared this valuation
oops too quick here I always change this
gambit continuation because it feels
like White has a big attack coming but
nowadays with computers I think this
line is believed to be okay for black
however Johnson played Knight c3
avoiding the porn SEC when just
returning with the night yeah this
continuation is some belief to be quite
harmless form yeah for ages actually
even back then when I looked at this
opening in the early early mid 90s
around that time I played that with
black um back then it was considered to
completely harmless but if you look at
the game now it's not that cousin scored
a bigger opening edge but it's certainly
a playable line that avoids any concrete
preparation um of course it's far less
aggressive but calm some emphasis is
clearly on the endgame let's see c5 and
83 C fibers the logical move
need to attack the center a three and
now we should a five just keeping the
bishop for the moment black also put
takács not a bad move and then just
continue developing but this position at
least Y has got the two bishops and it's
not clear that you want to give up your
bishop so early this move the certainty
all right neither three mod f6 yeah
white theoretically could take on c5 but
it looks very ugly to get just kind of
triple pawns and on top of that there's
a queen trait so not great so but should
be 396 of natural moves and now council
plays queen d3 move that at first looks
a bit odd because it get it simply a
place where you don't put your queen
normally that's a bit but it's taking up
a square that usually is used for the
bishop of course Bishop d3 is not
playable at all that can take but Queen
d3 is in fact the quite good move it
prepares long castles or a look to the
defiance on some other lines and it's
therefore quickly mobilizing forces
black takes and place Knight g4 this is
a debatable move it's not bad but it
leads to some imbalance now black invest
some time to get this this good Bishop
on e3 Dwight that doesn't really have a
choice he canceled Knight takes and now
you need to take with the pawn that's
the only movement Queen takes
unfortunately after Bishop e6 there's a
very nasty pin from the deform night
after yeah white now needs to make very
ugly move
like a 92 and you're still in the pin
black and simply a castle Queen f6 moved
like that so what must take with death
pond get another plate bishop see
certain not the move that probably
crosses your mind at first
castles maybe the more natural move but
if you compare 96 now do you see Queen
d8 this kind of man games this is very
similar to the to the game but in the
game the king is in the center I think
I'll not prefab that prefers that Bishop
c7 plate and this has an additional idea
to put the bishop on e5 this can be a
very good setup for black for instance
if White's tries a move like that
tonight to 3/5 try to get this bishop
then black can simply play Bishop e5 and
secure this piece and this kind of
position is very delicate if white plays
in a somewhat mistimes manner then he
can easily be worse against the two
bishops he needs to use the activity
that he's got at the moment the better
development basically after Bishop C
7000 played Knight takes c6 directly
going into the endgame recaptured check
and now we get this position should be
too
the bishop is aiming for f3 so how to
evaluate this position it's very
important to see that this Bishop on c8
is a problem please hope like it's not
able to find at the moment a good good
post it can only be developed to a
passive square like d7 o b7 white will
put the bishop on f3 and always
pressurize the week pawn on c6 in
general the pawn structure is slightly
better
why'd the three pawn is also weakness
but it's not as easily attacked as this
is six pawn in fact if black in this
position attacks the pond why term can
even look at lines where the spawn is
sacrificed but simply Luke t3 is also
good attending Bishop f3 this move does
not really help much that's also
Knightly form nvm he played King g7
which is perfectly alright Bishop f3 and
Bishop d7 yeah and tonight before all
this very logical the night intending to
go to c5 or go to g6 not replied Bishop
to b6 very logical attacking III and now
c5 was played all this was played rather
quickly and it's it just makes a lot of
sense of course now blacks reply is not
a bishop news um Bishop c7 for example
it's just too passive white will get the
knight to be six double on the D file
and it looks like some real pressure he
played there five this is much stronger
the ideas of course if the knight now
moves to any square here you simply grab
the pawn so there's only one reply white
needs to take on b6 takes on e4 and now
an important moment where white needs to
play the precise movement okay for
playoff counts and strength that's it's
an automatic reaction but still
something that many amateur players yet
don't really appreciate very often if
you
position where one of your pieces is
attacked and you can capture the
attacker like here Bishop takes the form
this kind of move is made almost
automatically not really thinking about
alternatives but once in a while you
have this this chance to make an
intermediate news or at solution soup
and the German borders is also on use in
English sometimes divisions ook ok and
this is b7 just advancing the spawn and
the taking a look
so black must play will create and only
now the recapture and hoop takes b7 son
in comparison to the immediate capture
on e4 let's just have a look at that
here black can take it has improved his
pawn structure this is now a pawn duel
we see that the pawn structure is
exactly identical two points those two
isolated pawns and the kings iPhones so
white would have absolutely nothing here
this is why he played b7 would be aged
and this kind of move order now Black
has a slightly worse pawn structure he's
got those three isolated pawns and white
has this little island b2 a3 and b3 so
with the additional asset of this Bishop
only four good piece white is slightly
slightly better but it's more symbolic
advantage it's nothing that you really
expect to convert to win I'm dumb rogue
one plate will be five activating the
hook on the fifth rank from example here
and you afford to be honest I think that
causal mostly is trying to
in this position - too slowly and
slightly improve the position but also
with time getting the yet with more time
getting used to somehow yeah
provoke I'm not a bit - to do some
active moves and maybe get some more
ideas - to attack blacks position I
think it is very very difficult to to do
anything constructive from right here
are not played g5 this is what I meant
it tries to provoke those moves it's not
a bad move at all but it gives some
additional ideas like rook f6 if the
Lukas double on the f1 has probably hook
f6 slight weakness its if it's perfectly
okay g5 but this is my my point he tries
to lure him and him a bit try to make
him do some selective moves to get some
additional ideas and this was also
possible and probably the move I would
have prefered it's not better than g5 or
anything just on general Browns I would
have liked to to inactivate this Bishop
iam getting it diagonal for that black
also should be okay here it's some very
important that the king is only seven it
covers important squares
well White's rooks may enter and I don't
really see anything dangerous here but
as mentioned the game move g5 is
perfectly okay look at 3 and h5 yeah
this is what I was getting at this is an
idea now we should be eights of course
covering
something you don't want to allow look
at seven and yeah Bishop see to the slow
improving move avoiding rookie five with
the temple yeah we have six it's a bit
more active them and also covers the
square white is playing and nothing
moves let's say I'm h3 or something then
Bishop do success oops
not this one mr. Bishop d6 is aiming to
set up this opinion very annoying so
this is why this move is plate covering
g 6h form and before yeah a form is a
bit a bit hard to understand because the
bishop now has some a bit limited but it
has got a concrete at the m we see that
causal strife or regrouping kingly to
and be the size idea once - woody form
take the d5 square away from blacks book
so that you can easily advance the king
it's still a very year we have very
drawing still white as the only one to
try a [ __ ] but it's it's very Jewish
King C champion group c5 check this is
basically not so much happening this
look of course wants to enter only two
so this is protected and roopd form
interestingly enough in the press
conference after the game island said
that your key form was maybe a very big
mistake that he committed this is not
really supported by by analysis I mean
by my analysis but also the computers
analysis it says that group divorce
perfectly alright
and like I made a mistake later so um
let's see brookey for seems very logical
to me actually activating the rook yeah
it allows that but this doesn't seem to
be a big problem like has this resource
bishop d1 and now after Bishop to be
warned I would be five like has discount
to play against the b3 porn council had
to calculated all this as as usual very
precisely in King c3 attacking the rook
and Luke doesn't really have many
squares you don't want to retreat it so
II five and now will be to yeah of
course
this looks a bit passive but at the end
this whole setup keeps White's position
together and these pawns that were
advanced couple of moves ago my turn
into weakness that can be attacked by
the lone wide rook c5 and rook g6 yeah
now I'm gonna place the sharpest move
with not much time on the chloe played a
form he also could have simply played G
for keeping the pawn and this also seems
to be yeah
leading to to a draw a very draw
position he played a for as mentioned
sharper still okay but it demands a bit
more precision I guess white took on
Jennifer
of course need to grab the paunch as
long as you get the chance and black.we
against the pawn on b3 check of course
II five is falling and back yeah around
here I am only around here I was able to
watch the live broadcast and it was
quite interesting to see that that many
spectators claimed us that this position
is a dead draw and and so on because the
engine tells them that this is a petrol
the engine goes to zero zero zero
relatively easily and quickly but to be
honest I didn't have an engine to to
analyze when I was watching on my mobile
phone and at this moment I was very
confident that that cars would win the
game but it's simply not so easy for
black to defend it's your porn down you
need to be precise maybe this is a draw
if the computer says zero zero zero it
is probably really a draw but the point
is okay what does zero zero zero mean it
means that with perfect play it's
probably and wrong but this also means
that black here has to play perfectly to
save the draw white can simply do the
things he he needs to do trying to make
some progress and not blundering things
and black really is walking this
tightrope so I thought that from
practical point of view this isn't so
easy if you look at the Nano system it
seems that Allan could have could have
drawn but it's not not so easy at all he
played rook t110e5 check came to d5 and
Bishop to h7 intending
this bishop check and here exactly in
this position we have them I think the
critical position of the game if if I
didn't have so much time to to analyze
this end game so I'm not 100% sure but I
think maybe the next one is already in
the decisive mistake it's clear that the
next move is a mistake this is really a
really quite obvious if you analyze it
but the question is is it really the
decisive one could you have done
something better a plate check a loop
see one check and the son at least leads
to very very serious trouble maybe it
loses I didn't find a safe but I'm not
100% sure maybe there was some chance
afterwards what black should do is Soak
a one in this position this was pointed
out by many spectators and and GM
commentators for instance by Nakamura
who was really a very surprised that
smooth wasn't played if you look at it
in let's say supported by by a computer
and internals and wholly not in a World
Championship merge situation you
relatively quickly see that this is the
better means but it's a different story
to to play it in such a such a situation
yeah we can look at lines bishop gah
check is the most challenging one
probably and one point is that Kings e6
we should be three black now has rook
takes a three and this is what secures
the draw of course we should continue
the line
where exactly is my line yeah King C
form takes qc3 stopping the the b-pawn
for the moment and here's King b5 Esther
the important is and that's absolutely
no way to make progress let's say rook
h4 that's look a tune and you have no
way to keep those two points together if
you play a move like Luigi for less the
pawned resource e4 and now like you're
threatening rook C 2 and this would even
win so you cannot even take on c4 and
once justice chain but white can channel
play this line and this isn't care of
course is completely dead you get the H
bond this is one critical line and of
course there are some some other lines
to consider and you cannot really tell
what detail aren't overlooked it's it's
it's not too hard the same in the gauges
mentioned to play group c1 and we can
say quite quickly what I see quite
quickly this doesn't really help like so
much you get this check in but you don't
have a look-see - for instance this this
Justin Bishop watching over c2 and
after.look g1 attacking the pawn check
White has got this this check and the
following is very forced
black needs to go back the hew advance
you you give up this this was checked so
like this check and this doesn't really
help at the end bill white keeps the two
passes something like that and you get
this at half the a pond and
addition so a complete winning yeah you
need to go back there's no choice
check and then yeah wide sit first if
this gets us check
yeah and it's not easy from like at all
he went back which looks a bit passive
at first but king b5 is not really a big
difference
after this White has a four as an
additional idea and the the big problem
is if black now takes on g2 check that
this position is is losing its no way to
to save to save this position as black
it's just too much this look is
protecting the point from the side and
what will possibly push the h-bomb I'm
sorry
in fact I'm glad that I can do this
video I hadn't have some cold and my
voice is surprisingly stable I'm glad to
manage to to do this at all okay the
check on age six and the King I went
back to the seven of course white takes
and we captures on b3 and the big
fundamental difference to the live with
rook a1 on new 45s that the a pawn now
is still on the board and in fact is the
decisive factor after rook takes rook
takes h4 the combination of whites
pesos is just too much i'ma tip late
King e6 which is maybe not the toughest
move around here you can try maybe to
improve on the defense but I didn't
really see something that that really
draws let's say look it sorry Mookie two
for example
um 8:45 King Savoy it also seems to be
winning for what I don't I don't see a
safe white will get the pawn and the two
there are positions with the to flank
points a and H pawn that are drawn but
this is not one of them so King e6 was
plate a4 and after that the combination
of the two pawns is too much okay
heaviness precise smooth cutting the
King and allowing no not like that
allowing hit the a pod to advance so
black he cannot stop this what check
gets the point to a 7 and after king c5
and age swamp he resides yeah black has
simply no recipe against the edge spawn
so the first win in this endless match
the first decisive game cars and winning
and to be honest I'm glad that we have a
win I'm not really not really rooting
much for one of the players but it's I
think it's a good thing to have a winner
I've had given a comparison to other
sports when matches often really get
spiced up when one side scores a goal
elite in some way that forces the other
side to to take more risks and in this
specific situation we tomorrow gets Game
six we're on on tests having the white
PC where honor does have the white
pieces and in the middle of the match
after six games in fact they switched
the color distribution so Arnold will
have white in Game six and in Game seven
this means that he's got two chances
with white and of course this is very
important if he scores a win to level
the match
would be of course excellent but he also
must be cautious not to over press
because I think if Carville would win
another game the match is over we won't
come back from a two-game deficit it's
difficult enough to come back from the
one game deficit it seems that Carson in
this match has the clear strategy to
avoid anything remotely looking like a
deep opening preparation you just play
some relatively non critical lines like
this one flank openings English opening
reti opening or here in this case this
early night c3 which is not really a
challenge look at this position this is
almost nothing probably there's nothing
but he continues and plays just very
precise moves you cannot criticize even
one of his moves it's just always the
best move or close to the best move and
Anand made probably only one really
serious mistake just check and this cost
him the game just just like that is the
strategy that Cowan is some employing is
probably just just the right match
strategy he is so far behind in opening
prep that he simply avoids anything like
that and concentrates on his strengths
and this is those kind of yeah endgame
type of positions where you can slowly
grind the opponent down and it's also
helpful that is yeah 21 years younger in
this kind of situation alright I hope
you enjoyed the coverage here of Game
five and I hope we get interesting Game
six in Game seven
well and we'll try to learn with the
scope with the white thanks for watching
I'll be back tomorrow with Game six